よろしくお願いします
今日は「人とどのように付き合いますか？」
というテーマで
大体2回ぐらい分けてお話をしたいと思っています
今まで仏教の話を日本で始めた時は
できるだけ具体的に日常生活の中の例を出しながら話してきたんです
なぜならば
釈尊の教えっていうのは日本にはなかった概念であって
仏教のような言葉がありましたけど
意味は全く違うもので
本当に馴染みのない話でしたから
で　あまりにも仏教っていうのは具体的で合理的で
科学的で
みんな聞きたくないという
そういうことがありましたね
初めは 宗教っていうのは神秘的で形而上学的で
科学とは関係ない
「何でもありき」の世界のような感じが普通
世の中どこでもあるんですね
超能力とか神通力の話とか
で　いわゆるわかりやすく言えば
我々の希望を叶えてくれる
欲望を叶えてくれる世界
「叶えてくれる」ということはおかしいんだけど
実際には叶えてくれませんけれど
ただ何かになりたいという欲望だけはあるんですね
その欲望は実際の社会では叶えてくれません
大金持ちになりたいとかね
世界一美しい人になりたいとか思っても
実際の世界ではそんなことにはなれないし
で　がんを治してほしいとかね
でも人間っていうのはそういういろいろな欲望・希望がありまして
宗教ではそんなことは何でもやってあげますよというふうな
もう全く非科学的なことばかり言って
で　そういうことにあまりにも馴染んでしまって
「しっかりと生きる道を教える」と（言うと）
なんかみんな嫌な顔をしたから
最初はいろいろ具体的な例を申し上げながら喋ってきたんです
一旦わかってきたところで
論理的に仏教というものは理解しなくちゃいけない
単なる例だけ聞いても
それは役に立たないんですね
ですから
論理的に
いわゆる仏教の方程式ですか？
それをわかってしまえば
自分たちでちゃんと何のことなくちゃんと生きていられるんですね
で　そういうふうに私は話の内容を徐々に変えていったんだけど
具体的な例を喋っていた時は
そんな具体的なことを言ったら
私たちはしっかりと「仏教は何ですか？」ということを知りたいんだと
もう反論されたんですね
僕の頭の中ではもうちょっと早いんじゃないかなと
で　たとえ四聖諦の話であろうが
中道の話であろうと
「ちょっと早い」んじゃないか？と
という気持ちだったんだけれど
で　それ（具体例）を話してて
「そろそろいいんじゃないかな？」と思って
論理的な世界に説明しようと思って（そうすると）
「いえ　具体的に話してください」って（言うんです）
どっちにすればいいか私には分かりませんけれど
「人間というのはそういうもの」なんですよ
「これはこれ」だったら
「いえ　違いますよ？」
「違う」と言うんですね
ですから
とんでもないんです
人付き合いは　人付き合いしにくいんです
で　簡単に喋ったら
「ああ　面白くない」
「簡単すぎです」と
じゃあそれだったら「一応しっかり喋ります」といって（喋ると）
「そんなに難しいこと言ったってわかるわけないでしょう？」と
短く喋ったら
「なんでそんなに短く喋るんですか？」と
「それじゃあ　わかりやすく説明して喋りますよ」と（言って喋ったら）
「そんなに延々と喋ったら
我々は忙しいんだ」と
（だからまあ）
その上　「うまく人間と付き合う方法も教えてくれ」と
「わかりやすい」と言えばこれ（うまい人付き合いの方法）ぐらいのものなんですよ
講演といえば これ（人付き合いの方法）で全部なんです
で　「やってみなさい」と
できるわけないと思いますよ
「人間と付き合う」ということは
こんな状態だったらね
ですから
私はそういう風にずっと
自分が個人的にやられて生きて
で　何をしても「それは違いますよ」という状態で
で　ということは
皆様も同じく　ひどい経験をして生きているということなんです
私だけではなくて
ああ　よかったという経験は中々ないだろうと思いますよ
ですから
世の中で「付き合いをしにくい存在」といえば　「人間だけ」なんです
それをまず覚えておいてください
社会性は全くなし
それから
日本でよく人気のある言葉というのは「和」ですか？
それは人間がもう夢の中でも「知らないこと」なんです
あれは全く完璧な嘘で
誰一人も「和」は知らないんです
で　そういうのは人間の中にはない
日本（の中）にもない
「和」っていうのは日本の言葉なんですけど
それは日本の言葉なんですけど
日本の社会にもなし
他の国々でもなしと
社会性はなし
でも「社会動物」っていうのは
「人間」だと　偉そうな哲学者や社会学者が定義するんです
人間というのは社会的な動物だよと
何を言ってるんですか？
ミツバチとかを見たらちゃんとした「社会動物」なんですけど
（それに比べて）「人間は何でしょうか？」とね
「俺が俺が」とかね
「我々」とかね
そういうことばっかりで生きてるんですけど？
ミツバチを見てください
「俺も女王になってやりたい」
「俺も女王になってやりたい」と思っているミツバチ
ミツバチはいませんから　みんなメスでしょうに
オス以外はね
まあオス以外はメスしかいませんのだけれど
で　ミツバチの中で　ほんの少ない数がオスで
他のみんなはメスなんですよ
あのローヤルゼリーを食べさせればみんな大きくなって
「女王」というかね
女王蜂になるんですよ
でもうまく「社会一つ」として「一体として」ちゃんとやってるんです
（ミツバチの）選挙は一度も聞いたことがないんです
僕はこの「ミツバチの中で女王を選ぶ選挙」とかはね？
「仕事を選ぶ選挙」とか
何もない
ただ　何のことなく自分自分の仕事をする
幼虫の世話をする蜂は　それをする
蜜を運ぶ蜂は　それをやる
蜂の巣の中に空気を
（何て言いますか）
換気扇ですか？
それ（換気）　空気を循環する人々（蜂）は
それ（換気）をちゃんとやる
守る　ガードをやってる（蜂も）
みんなそれぞれ自分たちの仕事をする
で　そこにはハチミツがいっぱいあるんだけれど
「私はいっぱい食べてやる」とかね？
そういうことをする蜂は　一人（一匹）もいないんです
ですから
そこ（内部）に見張り役はいりませんし
見張り役が必要なのは　（外から）「敵が来たらどうしようか？」ということだけ
ああいうのが本当の「社会生活」なんですね
人間にはそんなもの（本当の社会生活）は全くないんです
ですから
きつい言葉で言った方が分かりやすいので（そうしていますが）
別に私は「腹が立ってる」わけでも何でもないんです
一応　強烈にきつく言った方が
「頭に何か残る」だろうと思います
ただ　それだけのことで
ちょっときつく言うんです
「穏やか」に言ってしまうと何一つも残らないんですね
ですから
普通は我々出家の人々は徹底的に敬語を使って　大変礼儀正しく喋らなくちゃいけない
それは仏教では厳しく決まっているんです
で　私はそれを全部破って
全く違う（やり方で）
もう「できるだけ強烈にきつく喋ろう」と
で　その方が分かりやすいのは「分かりやすい」んです
そういうことで
一番こういう「社会性がない」
こう言ったら
「こう言えばああいう」というふうな状態っていうのが　人間の生き方なんですね
で　「それで問題が起こる」ということもまた当たり前のことで
自然の問題以外
動物の世界では問題は作らないんです
平和なんです
戦っている動物でも
それは戦うことは「自分の仕事」であって
別にそれ以上（のことは）何もないんです
「オス同士戦う」でしょうに
それは戦わなくちゃいけない
ただそれだけ
別に向こうに対して何か「怒り」とか何か持っているわけじゃないんです
「平和的」なんですね
人間の社会だけは　そういうこと（平和）は何もなく
なんの意味もなく戦ったり
相手を倒したりして
大変苦しい世界を作って
問題をいっぱい作っているんです
動物の世界で問題があったならば
それは自然破壊になったところで
みんな絶滅になるとか
それぐらいのものなんですね
我々の社会では自然と関係なく
いくら贅沢な生活をしても
戦いの世界
苦しみの世界は終わらないんです
そういうことで
まず理解するポイントは
「人間は一番付き合いしにくい
性格を持っている」こと
それから（次に）出てくるのは
「我々は人間と付き合って
いろんなストレスが溜まったりして
腹が立ったりして
悔やんだり
悩んだりしたりする
ありとあらゆる苦悩を味わっているということは
決して珍しい稀な経験ではありません」
ということ
人と付き合うことによって苦しみが生まれなかったならば
苦悩を味わうことはなかったならば
喧嘩にならなかったならば
腹が立たなかったならば
どこかで「おかしい」んです
ただそれだけ
「普通の付き合い」っていうのは
いつでもそういうことばっかりなんです
じゃあそれなら
それは「社会と付き合う時だけ」だよと
私は家族とだったら　大変仲良くしているんだよと
という人がいるかもしれません
それも正真正銘の嘘で
家族の中でこそ　いっぱい喧嘩をするんです
「一番わがままを言うのは家族の中」なんです
「自分本位」で言おうとするのは
ですから
家族っていうのは単なる「戦場」であって他の何物でもないんです
社会も同じこと
みんな誤解しているんですよ
この問題は「社会で」起こるんだと
家族は大丈夫だと
そうじゃないんです
社会でも同じく
家族の中でも同じく
ありとあらゆる葛藤や苦しみや悩むことが生まれるんです
生まれなかったら　（むしろ）「おかしい」んだと
それだけを理解しておきましょう
「人間付き合いがうまくいった」と言えばおかしくて
人間付き合いでいろいろ葛藤があるというのは「自然」だと
どこを探しても見つかりませんよ
たまに「もはや日本にはいられませんよ」と
ちょっとお金があったり
外国語を喋ることができる方々がいて
外国文化に触れたりして
外国に行ったところで大変気持ちが良かったとか
国が大きくて
物は物価が安くて
人が優しくて
で　日本はみんな時間に追われて「生きづらい」のだと言って
外国に住んでしまおう
住みましょうと思って行く人々がいるんですけどね
それももはや何と言いますか
甘い話で
そこへ行ったら
そこにまた　ありとあらゆる問題が生まれてくるんです
例えば　ある時期
日本の方々はハワイの土地を買い始めたんですね
「向こうは良い」よと
楽で　もう何の問題もなくとか
（それで）どうなったんですか？
「向こうに嫌われちゃった」んですね
買うな　来るなと
それでハワイの「なんとか政府」ですか？
まあアメリカですけど
その州の方がもう日本人が土地を全部買ってしまったら
我々はどうなるんだ
これは「なんとかしなきゃ」と
そこまで話が出てきたんだから
そこ（ハワイ）で向こうに嫌われて「こっちに来るな」って言われる
言われるのに
強引にお金で
お金の力で建物を買って住んでいても
「トラブルを起こさない」と思いますか？
起こしますよ？
それ（その原因）は「誤解」なんですよ
たまたま余興の旅行に行ったと
で　 1週間旅行すると
（その時は）「お客さん」だから
「本当の顔」は見せませんでしょうし
「1週間で帰る」んだから
もはや誰にでも　（ハワイの方たちは）できるだけ親切にしてくれる
それぐらいのことを理解しないのは何ででしょうかね？
「皆様もそう」でしょうに
自分の家にお客さんが来て
「1日泊めてください」と言われたら
一生懸命面倒見るでしょうに
すごい豪華な料理を作ってあげたりとか
「それじゃあ　あなた方の料理はすごく美味しいし
豪華でもあるので
これから私はこの家に住まわせてください」と言われたら　どうなるんですか？
それが現実でしょうに
それは外国に行っても同じことなんです
1週間ぐらいだったら（みんな）すごく親切にしてくれるんですよ
例えばアフリカみたいな
自然だけがある国に行っても
みんな自然の中だから
人を見かけて（そちらに）行ったら「来てください」と言いますよ
「ああ　こんな風に自然に溶け込んで生きることは素晴らしいことではないか」といって
日本人がそこに住むと
住んだ途端
その日本人が自分だけの「日本文化の箱」を作っちゃうでしょ？
それは　（彼らにとっては）すごい「異物」で
エイリアンみたいで
それから（以後は　彼らから）やられちゃうんです
いくら親切な黒人であろうとも
黒人というのはすごく
一般的にも「親切な人々」なんですけれど
大変な人とでも仲が良くなっちゃうし
でも　ああいうふうに
なにかちょっと異物的な
エイリアン的な存在になってしまったら
もうやりきれなくなっちゃうんです
ですから
この「どこへ逃げた」としても
人と付き合うということはかなり難しい
すごいきついんです
ですから
その「人とうまく付き合う方法」
（それを）これから話そうと努力はしますけれど
で　私は一つ二つ　今まだ悩んでるんです
論理的に厳密に方程式だけを言っておこうか
それとも大雑把に具体的な例を一つ一つ言っておきましょうか　と
論理的なことを喋ったら
皆様それを丸暗記でもして覚えれば　一生役に立つんです
その時々で使用できます
でもすごい「きつい話」になってしまう
難しくなるんです
それで　あっちこっちいろいろ具体的な例を喋ると
聞いてる時は　気持ちいい
それで終わり
（なぜならば）具体的な例だから
同じ例は二度と起きませんから
「ある子供とあるお母さんがこうやって付き合うべきですよ」と僕は言ったとしても
そういうケースはもう二度と起こりませんから　もはや「それっきり」で役に立たない
（今のところ　話す内容を）どっちにするべきか　私はまだ決めていないんです
そのうちに決めます
それで　テーマに入りますけれど
「人と付き合うのはなぜそんなに難しいのか？」と
だから今まで言ったのは
「これは難しい」と
「世の中で一番きついことだ」と
まず私は言いました
それをまず皆様は理解してほしい
もし嘘だと思うならば
「人と付き合うのは大変簡単だ」と思うならば
どうか今のうちに　自分の意見を述べてください
（もしも）それがなければ「皆様は（私と）同じ経験をしている」と思って仮定して　話を進めます
一応「普通の経験」で言えば
それは「そんなに簡単なものじゃない」のです
もし反論があるなら
反論的な心
（反論的な）気持ちでさえもあるならば
もう一度それ（人付き合いが難しいこと）を言います
戻って （例えば）完全に「自分に何かやりたいことがあった」とする
それに対して　自分の母親や
父親に（完全に）納得してもらった覚えがありますか？
私たちにとっては
世の中で一番我々のことを心配してくれる
一番心に近い
我々がどんなに悪いことをしても　許してくれる存在は両親なんです
何の恥もなく
何でも言える
頼ることができる
いわゆる「心のつながり」がものすごい強いんです
そういう自分の父親や
母親を説得することができますか？
子供に 僕にはできないかもしれませんけれど
ああ　私のお父さんだから
何のこともない
言ったらちゃんと納得してくれますよという
そういう経験があるならば
どうか正直に言ってみてください
私の知識で言うならば
自分の父親でさえ　母親でさえ
自分が何かやりたければ
それについて　説得すること
納得させることって至難の業なんです
「ものすごい難しい」んです
喧嘩して家出しなくちゃいけないんです
自分が何かやりたければ
それで（家出に）成功したならば
どうせ母親や父親だから
喧嘩して出て行っても
「なんとかあの子は無事で幸福でありますように」っていう気持ちはありますけれど
それにも関わらず「そういう状態」でしょうに
結婚して孫が生まれても
うちに「口も利かない両親」がいるんじゃないんですか？
ですから
自分の両親とでさえも　人間関係は難しい
やりにくい
ましてや　他人のことは「言うまでもない」と
ですから
「難しい」という立場で話さないといけない
いわゆる「不可能という立場」から喋りましょう
「人と人が付き合うのは不可能である」と
うまく（付き合うのは）　 それはなぜか？というと
今は皆さんにも　わかっているかもしれません
僕は前にも言いましたから
不思議なことに
人間はものすごい我儘なんです
わがまま
人間は「自分だけ良ければよろしい」という
気持ちで生きているんです
人間が自分個人の　自分の「個の幸福」を目指して生きているんです
それでどうなっているのか？といいますと
心のエネルギーは「自分の中」に入っているんです
「自分という殻」を作って
その中で
例えば円で（「自分」を）描くならば
例えば　「個」っていうのは「こういう風な生命」だと思うと
エネルギーは全部中に入ってるんですね
「外と関係ない」んです
「自分のことしか考えてない」んです
「それが原因」なんですね
問題が生まれてくるのは
それで　何のために我々は　その「自分の内しか考えない人」が
「何のために他人と付き合いたがる」んですかね？
他人と付き合いたがるのは
「自分の利益」のためなんです
我々が「他人と付き合いたがる」のは
その「この（自分の）利益のため」なんです
「損するために人と付き合う」人はいませんでしょう？
怪我するために　殺されるとも（しれない）
「殺されていただく」ために人と付き合う人がいますか？
いません
「自分の利益」のために
「幸福のため」に人と付き合いたがります
そうするとどうなるか？というと
付き合いたがる人が
相手もまたわがままで
自分のことしか考えない人で
その人とこの人が付き合っちゃうと
その人が損しちゃうんです
「相手（その人）が 損してしまう」と　これ「付き合ってはいけない」んですね
で　（相手と付き合うことで）自分に損をする人が
私（損する人）は「私のこと（利益、幸福）」を考えているんです
そこである人と付き合うと
私はいろいろ損をする
そうすると（ある人は）私の幸福を破る敵なんです
なんとなくちょっと論理的になりましたけれど
個人（個）が個人と付き合おうとすると
その「付き合いたがる人」が敵になっちゃうんです
その瞬間で
そこで人付き合いっていうのは成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
すごい厳密な論理なんです
で　もう一人も（このように書くと）同じく中に中に入ってる（内向きの）エネルギーを持ってるんですね
ですから
こちらにいる人がこちらから　（これからは全てエネルギーで考えましょう）
何もエネルギーを得られないんです
エネルギーは「中に入ってる」のだから
そこでこの人はこの人と付き合いたい
そこでこの人はこの人から「エネルギーを奪わなくちゃ」いけないんですね
だから（なぜなら奪いたいから）付き合うんだから（です）
そうすると
この人はこの人の敵に簡単になっちゃうんです
「数学」で考えてみてもいいんです
例えば「 1万円欲しがってる人」がいるんだと
そこである人に会って
あの人から
「1万円奪おう」と思っちゃった
そう思って　付き合ってみたら
「その人は（私から） 2万円奪おう」と思って私と付き合ってるとしたら
「敵同士」でしょうに
うまくいくわけないんです
もし私が「1万円が欲しくて人から貰いたい」と思ったら
もしも「お金が（沢山）ある誰か」がいるならば
「1万円あげたいな」と思っている人がいる（とすると）
そこで私が言って
「1万円くださいませんか？」と言ったら
「ああ　ちょうどよかった」と
私もこれをあげよう　と
誰かにあげようかな？と探していたところですので
ちょうどよかった　と気持ちよくくれるんです
そうすると人間関係はうまくいくんです
私が人から
「1万円奪おう」とすると
その人は私から
「2万円奪ってしまおう」と
お互いに何のことなく敵同士になるんです
そうすると人間付き合いどうやってしますか？
というと
相手は 1万円マイナス（1万円取られた状態）なんですけど
（私は）持っているものは相手に奪われないように
いわゆる 2万円を（相手に）奪われないように気をつけなくてはいけない
向こう側（相手）も私も
「1万円を奪われないように」と気をつけなくちゃいけない
だから「敵同士」なんです
そういう数字で考えると理解しやすいと思います
わがままだから
我々が生まれつきわがままの私が「自分のために」人と付き合おうとすると
その（相手の）人々は
（みんな）敵になってしまう
みんな自分の心にきつく鍵をかけて固くする
それでものすごい「敵同士の付き合い」になっちゃうんです
それが人間の付き合い方なんです
何のこと？（何をどうすればいいのか？）
何もできないんです（どうすることもできないんです)
一般社会論では
社会学的な知識では
そっちには解決策は絶対に見つからない
心理学者であろうが
どんなカウンセラーであろうが
どんな学校の先生であろうと
うまく「こうやってやってください」
と 「（こうすれば）うまくいきますよ」
と そんなことは全くありえないんです
「この基本的なこと（わがまま）を直すこと」は誰にもできませんから
たとえ我々が「人と付き合う方法」を教えても
それは「私のわがままをどうやって他人から満たしてくれるか」という方法だから
それは「ありえない話」なんです
ですから
そういうきつい条件の中で人間がお互いに付き合ってるんです
じゃあそんな中でも
一応　我々は人々と話をしたり
いろんな付き合いはしています
やっぱりよくわかりやすいでしょうね？
それはいつでもお互いの利害関係というか
「お互いに助け合う」ということによって成り立っているんです
私は人から何かを求める
その人は私から何かを求める
そうすると
その求める立場で仲がうまくいくんです
（しかし）それは「完全たる人付き合い」じゃないんです
じゃあ　わかりやすい例を申し上げると
若い男の人がいると
で　その人は自分の
欲望を満たすために（欲望があって）燃えているのだ　と
それはもうなかなかきつくて
何とかしてその火を
消してくれる人がいませんか？と思ったところで
若い女性が見つかる
そうすると
もし　その女性も「やっぱり男性誰かいた方がいいや」と思っていたならば
ちょうどうまい具合に「お互いに仲良く」なっちゃうんです
（しかし）それは「完全たる二人が一緒になった」わけじゃないんです
それぞれに　向こうはこちらからの何かを求めて
こちらは向こう側からの何かを求めていて
それでなんとか繋がりが生まれるのです
その二人がやがて結婚しても
二人は別々で
なぜならば
奥さんが他のところで旦那さんの悪口を言うのだから
で　旦那さんは旦那さんで別な世界を作っているのだから
別の仲間を作って
友達を作って
飲み友達を作ったりして遊んでいるんだから
「完全にお互いを繋げた」わけじゃないんです
繋がりません
「完全」には
そこで我々
ある人がある人と仲良くしたいと
友達になりたいと
でも　その人から見れば
私から「何も得るものがないんだ」と思ったら
もう迷惑な顔をして振り向いてはくれないでしょう？
ですから
現在　我々の人付き合いの場合は
そういう「何かの条件」の中でお互いに　この「助け合うやりとり」
「ギブアンドテイク」の状態が出来上がったら
「人付き合い」というものは出来上がるんです
ですから
それが社会にある皆様も知っている「人の付き合い」なんです
そこで
このギブアンドテイク状態が破れてしまったら
お互いにまた敵同士になっちゃうんです
たとえ 20年結婚生活をしていたとしても
もし旦那さんが浮気でもしたら
奥さんは腹が立って離婚
「離婚しますよ」って言っちゃいますから
その信頼関係を失ったら
「あなたを信頼していたのに」と
それで（信頼関係は）切れちゃうんですね
それぐらいの「弱い人間関係」なんですね
自分が育てた子供であろうとも
子供が「親から得をする場合」には親と一緒にいるんです
仲良くしてくれる
それである日になると
親から得るものが（なくなり　関係が）終わる時がくるんですね
終わったら親を敵に回して
出て行ってしまう
そういうふうな仕組みで　人間関係っていうのはできているんです
ですから
「（人間関係なんて）そんなもんだ」と思って
もう寂しく生きるしか方法はないと
人とは付き合うことはできないんだと
徹底的に孤独主義で
その時その時ほどほどに付き合って寂しく生きていくか
あるいは何か釈尊の知恵でも借りて
何か違う方法を見つけるかという
（そういう）ことなんです
（そこで）
一応論理的にはもうちょっとお話がありますけど
それじゃあ　お釈迦様の教えから言えば
どういう付き合いをすればいいか？と
一番大事なのは
まずその「私はわがままである」
それを正直に認める
「嘘を言わない」こと
この「嘘の戒律（嘘を言わないこと）」はだれ一人も人間というものは守らないんです
口では人に「何か言葉では嘘を言わない」んだけど
「生き方そのもの」は嘘だけ
嘘だけの塊なんです
どうしようもないんです
だから「真理」がわからなくなっちゃうんです
例えば
今私が言っているこの「わがまま」
「人間とはわがままですよ」という言葉でさえ　あまり聞きたくないでしょう？
「我々は神の子である」と
尊い魂を持っている
尊い素晴らしい「仏様の子供たちですよ」とか
なんとか言ったら気持ちいいでしょう？
皆様は体だけではなくて
心も美しく輝いてますよ　と
まあいくらでも言えますよ
僕にも「言葉の遊び」だったら
人を「嘘で褒めよう」と思ったら
私も結構上手だと思いますけれど
（実は）「本当に嫌な人」だったら「褒める」んです
自分が「（本当に）心配している人」は褒めません
全然（本当に）心配しているんだから
そん風なに褒めて（しまって）
何と言いますか
「人を落とし穴に入れて」はいけませんと
（相手が）どうしても邪魔で嫌で
迷惑だったら褒めてあげる
で　（その人は）褒められて
すごい落とし穴に落ちますけれど
それはそれとして
とにかく我々は　一般的に言えば
そういう風に皆様の体だけじゃなくて
心も素晴らしく綺麗ですね　とか言ったらすぐに気持ちよくなる
皆様　美しい清らかな精神
心　魂を持っているんだと
仏心菩提心持ってるんだ　と
「仏様の子供ですよ」と言ったら
誰でも「ああそうですか」
「気持ちいい話ですね」とか
「素晴らしい教えですよ」とか
なんとか「くだらないこと」を言うんです
そこで「何が嘘か？」というと
我々は自分がわがままであることは認めたくない
嘘をつきたいんです
ですから
ああいう風に言われると気持ちよくなるんです
「みんな醜くわがままですよ」と言われたら気持ち悪くなるんです
だから　どっちでも構いませんけれど
一応「中道的」な立場で
我々は　そんなにそんな難しい話ではなくて
「所詮生命っていうのは自己愛があってわがままで
自分のこと　自分の幸福
自分の利益を考えて生きているんだ」と
それを（まず）第1番目に理解する
第2番目に「私だけ」じゃなくて　もうちょっと合理的になりまして
「自分の子供も友達も　もう旦那も奥さんも
会社の同僚みんなも
社会も 人は誰であろうとわがままである」と
自分のことしか考えないものだと
そう理解する
その理解によって大体結構うまくいくんです
理解しておけば
そうすると腹が立たないんです
よく僕の耳に聞こえてくる話なんですけど
人々はお互いに話し合ったりして喧嘩すると
「あんた随分わがままですね？」とか言われるんですね
その時は「言ってる人」もすごく怒っているし
「言われる側」はさらに怒るんです
また（そういう）無茶苦茶なことを言うんですね
それをよく耳に入るんです
そういう話を
「あなたは随分わがままですね？」ということは
（言う人は）相手を非難するために言うつもりではないんです
（でも相手には）そう言われたら　相手を非難したことになっちゃうんです
それは当たり前で
今も喧嘩になっているのは
その人は「自分のこと」で喧嘩しているんだから
それを理解すれば
なるほど
「その人の立場」から見れば
「私はこういうふうに
間違ったんだ」と
そう理解できるんです
そうすると喧嘩にならないで
何とかなるんです
「あなたは随分わがままですよね？」
と言っても
言ってる人は何ですかね？
「言ってる人も随分わがまま」で
だから喧嘩になってるんだから
ですから（２番目に）
「人は誰であろうとわがままである」ということを理解する
理解してから（次に）どうするんですか？
3番目にこういうこと
これが大事なポイント
「何があろうとも驚かない」と
「何があろうとも驚かない」
これをきちんと覚えておいてください
我々人間関係
そういう「驚くこと」で壊してしまうんです
例えば「自分の子供は素晴らしいんだ」とえらく勘違いしていて
そこで万引きして見つかったと
認めたくないんですね
「我が子に限ってはそんなことは絶対ありえないんだ」と
よくも美しい服を着て
女性は「あんな醜いこと　聞きにくいこと」を口から出しちゃうんですね
本当にお母さんたちっていうのは
この頭が悪くて　すごく
頭悪いっていうのはそういうこと（子供のこと）でね
子供のことで「全く嫌な存在」になってしまうんです
ですから
こんなふうに驚いちゃうんですね
「私の子に限っては」と
例えば「自分の旦那さんがどこかで浮気したんだ」と話を聞いた場合でも
ショックを受けちゃって
ヒステリーを起こしちゃって
なんであんなに驚くんですかね？
それはその（「何があろうとも驚かない」についての）論理をわかってないからなんです
ですから
3番目に言ったこと
「何があろうとも驚かない」
なぜならば「何でもあり得る」からなんです
この世の中で
「生命」　その個が
その個々ごとに自分の幸福を考えているのだから
ですから
男っていうのは
（たとえ）自分の奥さんにものすごい忠実で
「一生（奥さんに）命をかけてますよ」と言っても
本人　知らないんですよ
この地球でどこか歩き回ってると
なんとなく「自分が気に入ってる人（好みのタイプの人）」とかがね
「目に焼き付く」可能性はあるんです
あるいは向こう側からいろいろ工夫して「誘惑される」ということもありえますし
そこで奥さんの前で誓いをしたとしても
「私はあなたに忠実でいます」
「（もしも）それを破ったら地獄に落ちますよ」とか何とか
それぐらいの誓いをしたとしても
そんな約束はもう通用しないんですよ
自分の心はどうなるか分かったものじゃないんです
すぐ「自分に利益あるな」と思ったら
そこへもう変化するという恐れがあります
ですから
人とうまく付き合いたければ
「何があろうとも驚きません」と
そうすればうまく付き合うことはできるんです
それを（知らずに）「驚く人々は全く無知」なんです
我々社会を見ていると
毎日いろんな問題が出てくるでしょ
そうするとまず「オレンジ共済」という問題があったりして
国会議員　でしょうに
で　最近この一番（の問題）は「野村證券」ですか？
問題があったり
それから今なんとか保険であったりとか
毎日なんですね
そんなことは
政治家が汚職するわ
宗教家が人を殺すわ
人をだますわ
それでみんな毎日驚きっぱなしで
「ああ驚いた
驚いた」と
やりきれないんです
それからまた次の人を信頼する
「ある政治家が汚職したんだ」と聞いてしまったら
次の人を選んで
その人を信頼する
で　「その人もなんかしてしまった」らまた驚いてしまって
じゃあ次の人選びます
「この人こそは」と
そんなこと（人のことを信頼すること）は世の中ではあり得ないんです
この「驚く」のはいいんだけど
がっかりするでしょ？
「がっかりしました」と
ある宗教が人殺しをやってしまったら
僕らにまでいろんなことを言われるし
そんな風にを言われているのに　またやってしまう
やるんです
同じことを
ですから
「何があろうとも驚かない」
これは人と付き合う時には抜群の
手段なんです
クールで
「あ　そう？」と
それで　例えば「一番悪い例」で考えましょう
自分の親戚か旦那さんか子供が「殺人」をしたんだ　と
もう対応できないでしょう？
そのショックで
自分でも自殺したくなっちゃうんですね
「ああ　嫌だ」と
「あれ　何ですか？」と
あれ　あまりにも驚きすぎて
もう何もできなくなってしまうんですね
今まで大変いい子でいた自分の子供であろうが
何一つ微かな悪いこともしなかったかもしれませんけれど
なんかどうも殺人を犯してしまった　と
そうなったら何のことなく　「そう？」と驚かない
驚かないでいる間に　子供へ
「どういうことかな？」と
聞いたら　それを全部説明してくれるし
それで「そういう場合は　こうこうこういう風にすればいいんじゃないかな？」と
知恵も生まれてくるんです
もし殺人を犯した子供へお母さんが面会に来たとしても
顔を合わせたくないんですね
なぜならば
泣いたり喚いたり
ヒステリーを起こしたり
「私はそんな風にお前を育てたことはない
なんでそんなことを？」
そんな感じで喋るのだから
ですから
子供は自分の立場を言えなくなっちゃうんですね
「驚かない場合」は何のことなく
お互いの心は通じ合う
「通じ合う」だけじゃない
対策方法
問題が起きたら「どうするべきか？」と
それも何のことなく出てくる
そういう風に人付き合いの場合は
これこそ一番必要な
「これ一つ」で（人付き合いが）出来るんです
「何があろうとも驚かない」ということ
なぜならば
「何でもあり得る」のだと
男で生まれる男の人々が
「女」になっちゃう世界だから
最近　あれは「医学的に不可能」なのに
医学的に不可能なのに　こうなっちゃいますね
あれに驚くんですか？
私は驚きませんよ
「あ　なるほど
あの子の気持ちだ」な？と
「女になりたがっているんだ」と
それだけのことでしょうに
もし私に親切な人だったら
僕は助けてあげますよ
いろいろ「相談にのってあげたり」とかね？
「どうした方がいいか？」　とかね
これ（性転換）の得と損
あなたがこれをやったら何を損するか
何を得するか？　とかね
で　仲良く相談にのってあげますけどね
そういう人は今まで（出会った人の中には）いなかったんだけど
一応　「あったとするならば」　僕は驚かない
そこで親が　母親が「ショックを受けてしまう」のだ　と
別に自分の子供だからと　別に驚かない場合は
何か「ディスカッション」ですか？
「話し合う」ということはできるんですね
話し合うことによって
両方ともにいい結果が出てくるんです
そういうことで
我々は人付き合いの場合は
「何があろうとも驚かない」という論理で
生きていくように努力してみましょう
確実に上手くいくんです
で　小さい子供を面倒見る時でもね
ちょっと何か間違いを起こしたら
お母さんが「キャーキャー」といちいち言ってしまうでしょうに
だから女性の体っていうのはすごい
ものすごい強いでしょ
それでよかった
あれほどヒステリーを起こしたら
男だったらもう二十歳になったら死んでしまいます
よくもね
24時間ヒステリーだけで生きてるんだから
だから自然の不思議さというのは
それぐらい女性には「生命力」ですか？
生命力はついているんですけど
ですから
例えば自分の子供の場合でも
何かしたら
「ああ　またやったんですか？」
とか　「なんでそんなことをするんですか？」とか
すぐもう驚いてるんですね
ヒステリーを起こしてるんですね
そこで「間違いを起こした子供」も嫌なんですね
たとえ自分が間違いを起こしても
「ああいう風に言われる」のは嫌なんです
なんでそんなことをするんですか？
と本人もわかってるんだから
この世の中で「自分を忘れて」みんな考えてるんだからね
真理わからないだけで
この世の中で
じゃあこれから
悪いことをしよう
「これから失敗しよう」と思って行動する人がいますか？
じゃあ奥様方
考えてください
「今日の料理は失敗します」と
そういう風に料理した経験あります？
ないでしょう
ある？（笑）　ないでしょう
だから人間っていうのは
「今日の料理は美味しく作りますよ」という気持ちでやる
その過程で失敗するんであって
別に自分のせいじゃないでしょうに
だから本人が知ってます
「あ　今日はちょっと失敗だ」と
焼きすぎだと
煮すぎだと
塩加減がちょっと今日はまずかったとか
味付けはちょっとまずかったと本人も知ってるんですね
それで旦那さんから「今日はまずいな」と言われると腹が立つんじゃないんですか？
自分の腹が立つんだけど
子供に平気で同じこと言うんです
（子供が）何か間違いを起こしたら
ですから
このうまく人と付き合う場合は
こういうことを考えてほしいんですね
人は誰でも「失敗します」と
今度は（失敗します）と思って行動はしない
誰でも　行動する過程で成功か失敗かっていうのは
それは別な話で
これ別な角度での価値判断なんですね
自分が真面目にやりたいんです
結果としてどうであろうと
それで結果として失敗だと思ったら
我々は腹が立つんじゃなくて
ああ　別に驚かないんだからね
まあそんなことはまあどうせあり得ることだから
ああそう
失敗したの
それだけのことなんですね
子供だと「失敗しちゃったの？」
その一言葉で全部直るんです
本人を貶した訳でもないし
こちらがヒステリーを起こした訳でもないし
まず　すごく
気持ちがいいんです
子供は「やっぱり母親はよく理解してくれる人だ」という
ものすごい愛情が生まれてくれるし
こちら（母親）はヒステリーを起こしてないんだから
向こう側（子供）は次に失敗しないように気をつけるし
子供の場合は
あ　その場合はね
「こうすれば失敗しないよ」と教えてあげればいいんだからね
包丁を取って怪我したならば
子供は包丁は持たないよ
包丁をどうしても掴みたければ
「こうやって握るんだよ」と言って（教えて）あげればいいんです
もし子供が包丁で怪我をしたら
母親はどうするんですか？
「なんであんたこんなことするんだ！」
「ああだこうだ！」とかね
そこで旦那さんにまで「お前が悪いんではないか」と
また（旦那さんが）怒られたり
病院に行ったら　お医者さんにも怒られたり
「どうして子供にそんな物を触らせるんですか？」
と　もう踏んだり蹴ったりの状態で　みんな間違ってるんです
怪我をしたら
まあそれはそれなりに治療してあげて
「あのね　包丁は危ないよ」
「痛いでしょう？」とかね
「じゃあこれから気をつけましょう」と
あるいはどうせ子供は大きくなるものだから
包丁はこういう風に掴みます
いつもじーっと握っておきますよ　と
で　握らせてあげれば
「これぐらい硬く握らなきゃダメだよ？」と　子供に出来ないぐらい筋肉で硬く握らしてあげたら
子供は「やっぱりこの遊びはやめましょう」と自分で自発的にやめてくれるんです
ですから
そういう風に面白く生きていられるんです
「驚かない」ならばね
それは社会的に
子供の世界で我々が生きているわけじゃないから
大人の世界だから
社会の中でも何が起ころうとも驚かないで
落ち着いて物事を見ていると
うまく人間関係を（作ることが）できるんです
私たちの悪いところは
「自分も間違う」のに
失敗だらけの人生なのに
他人から完璧さを求める
他人の過ちは許さない
腹が立つ
説教したくなる
それはもう単に「人間の間に爆弾をしかける」事と同じなんです
それには何の意味もないんです
いちいち
終わりなく
喋るは喋るは
誰かが失敗したら
1 日中喋る
次の日も喋る
そこでまた「人間関係がうまくいってほしいんだ」と（言いつつ）自分で壊してるんだから
ですから
「楽しく　明るく」ね
人の失敗を見たら別に驚かない
「当たり前だ」と
私に言わせれば
「人が人を殺すこと」も当たり前なんです
一人の人が
10人 20人を殺しても
それもまた当たり前なんです
「ありえないこと」ではないんです
ある人が頭が狂ってしまって
もう1万人
10万人でも人を殺そうと思うかもしれません
そういうのは世の中で
そういうことでさえ当たり前だからね
明日でも今日でも大地震が起きて
我々みんながパッと消えてしまうかもしれませんし
何でも世の中であり得るものなんですね
もし5時になっても
6時になっても
7時になっても太陽がそのままだったら驚いてください
9時になったけど
太陽はそのままだったら
本当に驚いて欲しいんです
それで地球が止まってしまった
1箇所で止まってしまったら
それ以外はね
あんまり驚くことは世の中にないんです
なんでそれに驚くべきかというと
「ありえない話」だからね
ありえないことがあったら驚く
なぜならば
それは人類の命に関わりますから
そうでないものには驚かないと
まあ　だいたいそれぐらいで結構
人間関係っていうのは
うまくいくだろうと思います
一旦そこら辺で一つのポイントとして
（今のところ）1時間は喋りましたけど
何時まで？ 5時？
じゃあそのまま続けますか
ん？ ちょっと質問していいですか？
はい  あの
「驚かないということ」ってわかるんですけど
「仏教は科学的だ」っていうふうに思えるんですけど
それから「個」っていうのは「エゴ」ですから
どうしても「自分が」って
それは非常に現実だと思うんですが
もう一つ
「弱肉強食」っていうのがございますね？
生物界っていうか
動物　生物界って植物もそうなんですけど
動物　生命というのは弱肉強食だと思うんです
ですから
やっぱり人と付き合う中で
「エゴの問題」と
もう一つ「弱肉強食の視点」というのはどういうふうに考えたらいいでしょうか？
うん この「弱肉強食」のことも
この「エゴの問題」から出てくるんですね
エゴだから存在はいつでも弱肉強食ということになっているんですね
ですから
我々はその代わりに何か「共存する方法はないかな？」と仏教は考えているんです
「競争」の代わりに「共存」の論理がないかな？と
そう考えているんですね
でも　「理想的な共存の世界」は成り立たないんです
「できるだけ共存的な世界」を作ろう　と
というのが仏教のプラクティカル的な教えなんですね
実践的な教え
理想的な共存社会は成り立たない
なぜならば個は存在しているんだから
仮にでも
ですから
それから一つの論理は
この「競争」すると（弱肉強食と同じことですけど）
「苦しみ」しか生まれてこないと
たまにでも共存すると
なんとなく気持ちいいと
幸福だと
それだったらそちらの方をできるだけ増やそうというぐらいしか
その問題については答えがないんです
お釈迦様もそのことは何か考えて
それは全部　僕も結構（考えて）あるんです
ヨーロッパとか現代の社会は競争社会ですよね
人間の個の競争心を煽って
人間を酷使しているというところがあるわけですね
公平の思想だと思うんですけど
それに対して仏教的な世界の思想は
競争社会を抑える方法があるんですか？
抑えるというよりは
この「競争社会」っていうのは「泥棒の社会」だからね
現代ヨーロッパ的な経済っていうのは
人のものを盗んで自分の幸福にする
ただそれだけ
弱い者をいじめて
人のものを自分で盗んで食べているんですね
それで社会は発展しているごとく見えるんだけど
自分が自業自得でもう破壊しちゃうんですね
お釈迦様は言うのは
やがてあなた方は自分で自分たちを破壊するんだと
一時的にある人に金があるように見える
ある国にお金が溜まっているように見える
でもその国さえも幸福ではないし
その国が他の国々が貧しくなければ成り立たないんですね
ですから
「人を不幸にして自分が幸福になる」という経済論理は
仏教はどうかな？と
それを「良くない」とは言わないんだけど
一応それは「不善たる道」だと
商売の場合でも
私はこういうものは持っていて
でもこういうものは持ってないんだと
ですから
お互いの
何て言いますか
コンプロマイズ
お互いの理解のもとで
じゃあ交換しましょう
それで私も幸福で
あなたも幸福ですよ
そういう経済なんです
ですから
物を売るのはいいんだけど
買った人は幸福にならなくちゃいけないんです
いわゆる現代の経済用語で言えば
この ...使用する人
何て言いますか
「消費者」 消費者がいて　欲しい品物は会社で作らなくちゃいけないんですね
今は逆なんですね
工場で勝手に自分勝手にものを作って
強引に売ってる
宣伝して　買ってみたら
こんなものは「要りません」と
使えないんだと
たとえ電気炊飯器にしても
コンピューターがついてるんだ
ああなってるんだ
こうなってるんだと言うわ
言うわ　言うわ
誰一人その機能は使わないんです
まあ米洗っといて
まあスイッチ入れるだけ
それだったらスイッチ１本でも（いいはず）　そういうものもあってもいいんだけどね
とにかくまあそれはそれでいいんだけど
工場の方が自分勝手に新しいものを作っておいて
強引に売りさばいちゃうと
お客さんが完璧には喜ばないんです
それで摩擦が生まれてくる
宣伝しなくちゃいけない
宣伝するためにお金がかかる
そうするとまた値段が上がっちゃう
そうすると「どうでもいいもの」を作るんだから
他の会社も同じことを作ってしまっちゃう
ライバルがさらに出来上がっちゃう
それでとことん
使用する人々（消費者）が責められていじめられる
やがて購買力が消えちゃう
そうすると会社も倒産すると
その現象が毎日見えてくるんです
毎日　ですから
そうじゃなくて
私は何か持っていて
ものでもいいし
能力でもいいし
他人がそれを持ってない
その代わりに私が持ってないものをその人は持っていると言ったら
（これを）いかがでしょうか？と
あなたはこういうものを持っていて
私は持ってないんだけど
私はこういうものを持っていて
あなたが持っているものと
どうですか？と
交換的な立場で
「交換原理」はありますけど
これやっぱり「得しよう」という原理がありますからね
交換の場合は相手から得しなくちゃいけないんですね
そこはちょっと良くないと
「得すること」じゃなくて
「お互いに満足」すればいいんじゃないかと
ということで
「ものの値段」っていうのはある「存在するもの」ではなくて
人のこの「ニーズ」
「ニーズ」って何でしょうかね？
「人がどれぐらいそれを要求しているか？」ということによります
そういう経済的な概念が
いくつかあります
別に経済学ということはないんだけどね
いろいろ推測しなくちゃいけないしね
世の中このまま流れますからね
破壊するまではね
そんな仏教的になるという見込みは全くないんです
それも驚かないんですか？
驚かない
全然  弱肉強食に驚かないんですか？
全然　それは真理だから
驚いてもどうしますかね
そういうのは全然驚かない
だからいろいろ生きる方法っていうのはその中から出てくるんです
驚かないんだから
それは「慈悲」っていうことと何か関係あるんですか？
これからそれを喋ろうと思っているんです
じゃあ　一休みということで
これは次にまた２部として始めます
じゃあ 3番目として
この「何があろうとも驚かない」ということから
我々は「人と付き合う方法」を見つけることができます
それから次のポイント
私はわがままで個的な存在で
自分のために生きてるんだと
ということで
私は人から「何か得をしよう」と思うと
その人は敵になるんだと
人と付き合いたいんだけど
いかがですか？
あなたとあなた
私と仲良くすれば？
と言ったら
その瞬間でその人達は敵になってしまう
また他の人と話してみたら
その人もまた敵になってしまう　と
そういうことで
自己　個があって
個が自分のために行動しちゃうと敵ばっかり作る
一番いい例というのは
だいたい日本はどうかわかりませんけれど
いっぱい人々の共感を得て人気があって得る仕事があるんですね
政治家みたいに
政治家が大統領やら総理大臣やら国　天下を取ったところで
結果はその人に限って「敵だらけ」なんです
ありとあらゆる警備
警備　警備
警備とか
国の選挙で国民の選挙で選ばれた大統領がどこかへ行くと
1週間　 2週間前からその地方の全部警察がみんな調べる
大変なんです
私も何回もそういうひどい目に遭って
絶対政治家のところには行かない
日本だったら別に問題ないんだけど
自分たちの国だったら
大統領なんかが来ると言ったら
会うことになっちゃったら
まあ体中全部調べるわ
カバンの中はもう片っ端から見るわ
財布は開けてみるわ
それをお坊さんだから（そこは）問題ないってこと知ってますけど
やっぱりそれでも決まってるんだから
もうやらなくちゃいけない
そこで車を止めようと思ったら
もう大体 500メートルぐらい遠くへ車を止めなくちゃいけない
そこから歩いて行かなくちゃいけない
ああだこうだ
この警備の厳しさ
たまに頭に来るんです
もう「我々が選んだやつと会うためなのになんでこんな目に」という風に
腹が立ってしょうがないんですね
結局そこは同じ論理なんです
「人から人気があって選ばれた」ということは
その人はいろいろ甘い話をして
「どう　私にちょっと投票したら？」という話でしょ
そのことによって　その人はいっぱい敵を作っただけなんです
今の自分の国の大統領は女の人なんですけど
こういう話をしたんですね
大統領になる前にはね
みんなとよく仲良くできたんだと
時間とかに関係なく
みんなと一緒にご飯を食べたり
誰とでもよく喋る
大変優しい人でしたけど
今は一般の人と会う機会は全くないんだと
なんか全く別な世界で
別世界で隔離されて生活しなくちゃいけないと
これで政治はできっこないんだと
一般の人の悩み苦しみが全然わからなくなっちゃったんで
隔離されちゃって
そんなもんで　敵になってしまうんです
ですから
個が自分のために「人と付き合おう」と思っちゃうと
「その人が敵になっちゃう」という論理は前に言いましたね？
そこで「こういうことをやってみたらいかがですか？」と
私は私の幸福を願っている
まあ　それはしょうがない
他人も他人（自分自身）の幸福を願っている
私は一時的に私の幸福をいったん置いておいて
他人にちょっとだけ幸福を与えたらどうですか？と
この自分の中に入っているエネルギーを
ほんの少々でも外へ向けておく
それ英語でintrovert（内向的）という言葉が
2つあります
これに　ちゃんとした日本語の言葉はありますけど
僕はあまり思い出せませんけれど
普通の世界で
このintrovert（内向的）っていうのは
この自分の内へ何か考える
自分のことを考える人
何て言いますか
内向　内向？
「内向性」と言うんですね
それであまり内向性はいいと思ってないんです
普通（世間）でも心理学の世界でも
このextrovert（外交的）というのはすごい社交的で
大体社交性ある人々はみんな人気があって
大変うまくいってるでしょ？
で　それは一般的だからあんまり意味がないんです
僕が言ってるのはもうちょっと違う
私が言うのは
所詮「人間が内向的」なんです
「全てみんな」
この心理学で言っているように
ある人が性格として内向的で
ある人が社交的でというのではないんです
それはちょっと社会の上の　上辺だけ見て言っていることで
なぜならば
なんで社交的かというと
その方がその人は幸福を感じているのだから
ですから
このintrovertってのは内向的で
extrovertってのは社交的という意味で
で我々は 我々の心の中から
ほんのちょっとだけでもいいんだから社交的になる
自分の幸福を考えることを置いておいて
まあちょっと人も助けてあげたってもいいんじゃないか？と
それを強引にやらなくちゃいけない
自然的じゃないんです
覚えておいてください
例えば
2人がどこかへ遊びに行って
2人で
友達2人が話して
じゃあ私は料理作ってきます
ある人はじゃあ私はご飯と
味噌汁を作ってきますから
じゃあ私はお菓子作ってきますよ　と
それで作っておいた　お互いに　自分が二人分ご飯作って味噌汁作って
向こう側が二人分お菓子を使って
それでお互いにうまくいっちゃうでしょ？
弁当分けて食べられる
そういうことでは
自分が 2倍ご飯炊くんだけど
人に一部あげる気持ちじゃないんですね
向こう側がお菓子持ってくるんだから
その代わりに半分分けるぐらいのだけのことであって
そうじゃなくて
じゃあ二人でどこかへ行こうと決める
じゃあそれだったら私は弁当二人分も作りますからと
あんたは楽に来てくださいと
というような形なんですね
いわゆるその考え方は
あんたも私は損するんじゃないか
その場合は
と その人の弁当は
その人勝手に買ってくればいいんじゃないかということじゃなくて
これは論理的に言ってるの
この例出しても論理的に考えてください
人は幸福を求めている
今の場合は
昼ご飯　弁当を食べたがっているようなことで
じゃあそれ　ちょっととしてあげればどうですか？と
余計なお世話かもしれませんけれど
ちょっとしてあげればどうですか？
それは決して余計なお世話にならないんです
なぜならば
どんな子も社会から幸福をちょうだい
幸福をちょうだい　というふうに叫んでいるんだから
その中で一人が　「いいわ
少し余分に幸福を作ってあげます」と
あなたに
で　何かしてあげると
そういうふうに心のエネルギーは外に向かうと
ほんの少々　強引に　その向かう外に　向かうたびにたびに
社会関係というのは何のことなくスムーズにいっちゃうんです
例えば　一人の人をそういうふうに助けてあげたと
助けてあげたならば
自分が見返りは求めてないし
見返り求めたらもう全く普通なことだから
普通な付き合いだから
見返りは求めていないし
助けてあげただけ
そうすると
その人が自分の味方になるんです
敵ではなくて
それしかないんです
「今までしていた　人との付き合い方」というのは
「敵同士の付き合い方」なんですね
お互いに利害関係で付き合ってるんだと
もうやむを得ず付き合ってるんだけど
本当は敵ですと
ですから
夫婦っていうのは敵同士なんです
親子っていうのは敵同士なんです
もう悲しいことに
お互いにいろいろ求めるものがある場合は一緒にいるんです
求めるものが消えちゃったら
もう敵同士で別れちゃうと
そうじゃなくて
本当の味方ができちゃうんです
ですから
うまく社会関係とか人間と付き合うためには
自分がポジティブ的に行動的に見返りを求めないで
社会の中で行動する
そうすると触れる触れる人が味方なんです
どんな人に触れても
その人は味方です
すごい大雑把でわかりにくいんですね
まあ　これからちょっとわかりやすく
いろいろ例を出して考えてみましょう
一番わかりやすい例というのは
皆様も　すぐ感じるのは
いろんなことを人にしてあげたって
なんかその人は「ちょっとなんか悪いな」と感じるでしょ？
皆さんはそうでしょ？
もし隣の奥さんがいつでもいろいろ
大変高価なお菓子とかね
京都に行ったら京都のお菓子買ってくるわ
大阪に行って
広島に行ったら広島のものを買ってくるとかね
それがまた高価なものだと
自分が全然旅行はしないし
そうするとなんか立場が悪くなるんじゃないんですか？
隣の奥さん
いつでもどこかへ旅に出ると
旅に出たらなんかお土産物を買ってくると
私は子供のことで忙しくて
全然スーパー以外にはどこにも行けませんと
というふうなことで
なんとなく人のあれ（好意）も受けたくなくなっちゃうような気持ちが生まれるんですね
それをよく理解してください
それは普通なんです
なぜならば
人間の関係っていうのはギブアンドテイクの関係だからね
そうでなきゃうまくいかないんだから
そういうふうにきつく感じる
それは正しい
それで我々は奥様の役をやってくださいと
隣の奥さんの役をやってくださいと
今言ってるんです
いわゆる余分に　余分とは言わないんだけど
人に　人を助けてあげてください
人にいろんなことをしてあげてくださいと
そうすると
向こう側がすごくきつく
心の痛みを感じるんじゃないかな？という問題が生まれてくる
そこはポイントなんです
ポイントっていうのは
もし私が誰かに何かをしてあげた
そうすると
その人はやっぱりこの恩を返さなくちゃいけないなと感じたら
私はいいことをしてないんです
それは　単なる普通のギブアンドテイクの行為なんです
言う？　文句言うでしょ？
あの人にお中元を送ったのに
お礼状も返ってこないんだ　とかね
なんだろうか？と
なんで腹立つんですかね？
自分勝手に中元送っちゃって
やっぱり中元を送って向こう側喜んでくれると
こちらが勝手に人の心のところまで計算して
向こうも知ってるんだから
一応義理で送ったんだから
大変素晴らしい高価なものをありがとうございます
ああだこうだとかね
そこまでしなくてもいいのに　とか
よくも嘘ばっかり　とかやって生きてるんですね
嘘の塊でしょう？
そんなものは
そこで
そういうことだから
我々は人に何かあげても
「お礼ぐらいはしろ」という見返りは求めちゃう
それで友達ができあがらないんです
ああ　めんどくさいなという
という関係しか生まれてこないんですね
そこで我々は人に何かいいことをしてあげると
向こう側はなんのことなく
その恩恵を受けられるように
我々は落ち着いて
全く何のことなくしてあげなくちゃいけない
例えば　まあわかりやすい例で
「2人で弁当を食べてるんだ」と
自分がちらっと見たら
やっぱり向こうの弁当よりはこちらの方が豪華ですよと
そうすると
あ　これどうですか？
と言ったら
向こう側も何かこちらにくれなくちゃいけなくなるでしょう？
で　それではうまくいかない
そうじゃなくて
本当に これもう食べられないんだけど
こっちでてもらってくれる？
半分もらってくれる？
助かりますよと
こちらで「お願い」するような感じで
このこれ
今日はこの鶏肉の何て言いますか
作ってきたんだけど
本当　あんまり多すぎて食べられないんだけど
ちょっともらっていただけますか？と
助かりますよと
言ったら向こう側も遠慮するかもしれませんけれど
「どうぞどうぞ」と言ったら
「ああ　よかったよかった」と自分で楽しめば
「ああ　助かりました」と
言っちゃえば
向こうは何にもストレス感じないんです
自分の梅干しをあげなくちゃいけないと
そういうふうに自分が何か　人に何かしてあげるんじゃなくて
何て言いますか
この場合
日本語で「やらせていただいているんだ」と
そういうふうに行動すると
相手側は何のストレスも感じない
その代わりに本当に素晴らしい人だと
なんか優しい人だ　と
それは頭で感じない
なんか波動がね
雰囲気がいいんですね
その人と一緒にいると
それで一人の人が味方になった
だから「後で何かお願いします」と「からくり」やっちゃったらもうダメなんですけれどね
今いろんな親切をしてくれるのは
後に　 1年
2年後に何か　という状態ではないんです
ですから
この「ウチ」に「内向的な我々のエネルギー」を　人を助けてあげようとする
それで人が得するようにする
で　「エネルギー」っていうのは「入ったら返さなくちゃ」いけないんですね
ですから
同じく　私が人の弁当を食べたならば
私もいつかその人にそれなりの弁当を買ってあげなくても
他の何かをしてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると
私は「その分を払わない」限り
「ツケ」ですか？
エネルギーとして残っちゃうんですね
あ　「なんかしてあげなくちゃ」と
たとえ年賀状をもらっても
年賀状をもらったと
自分がその人に年賀状を出してないんだと
もう時期遅くなっちゃったんだと
時期も終わっちゃったと
言うと　じゃあ来年出しますと思ったら
1年間も！　（私はよくやりますけどね）
で　 1 年間もあの「ストレス」を心の中に持たなくちゃいけないんです
ですから
そういうことではダメだと
我々は人に何かしてあげるんだけど
その人の心の中で
あのマイナス的な
この「払わなくちゃいけない」という「余分なエネルギー」は溜まらないようにしてあげると
で　見てください
皆様もご家族
ご家族を持ってますから
自分で経験があると思いますけど
子供たちとかね
見ていると
知らない人が何かお菓子でも　チョコレート一つでも
ポテトチップス一つでも　「どうぞ」とあげたら子供は遠慮するでしょ？
そこでお母さんの膝の上にポテトチップスの袋があると
子供は何のことなく手を出してパクパクと食べる
それでお母さんがやめなさい
やめなさいとぶん殴らなくちゃいけないんです
そこまで（やらないといけないことになる）
そこで子供は何のストレスも感じないんですね
「後で払わなくちゃいけない」とかね
「ああ　ありがとう」と
「申し訳ない」とかね
「悪いですね」
とかね 「恐縮ですね」とか
そういう気持ちは何も感じない
「やめなさい」と言われながら
またお母さんの前にまた手を出して
また取って食べると
それで子供は最高に幸福でしょう？
なぜならば
母親が何も見返りを求めないであげてるんです
すごい気持ちがいいんですね
お互いに
子供が食べるとそれほど面白い幸福がないんですよ
自分の子供は
自分が一生懸命作ったものはむちゃくちゃ食べると
「むさぼって食べる」とすごい気持ちいいという「幸福を感じる」と
そういうふうな感じで
幸福はそこに　我々の目の先に
鼻の先にありますから
それは他の人に対してでも　微かな　微かなことでも
見返りなしにしてあげようと
向こうは悪いと思うけど
いいということ
どうせ私には余分なものだからね
助かったのはこちらですから
気にしないで
気にしないでと
という風に言って
相手をリラックスさせてあげる
それでなんかうまい人間関係が
生まれて
それはこの我々
みんな仲がいいと
「世界は兄弟だ」と「手を繋いで首に手をまわして踊っているような関係」じゃないんです
別に なんとなく
なんか空気のようにお互いにすごく
いい関係が生まれてくるんです
それはいわゆる慈悲といえば慈悲の働きなんですね
慈悲はあくまでもこの「自我」という気持ちを
この気持ちを壊すんです
慈悲の瞑想によって
個という概念が破れちゃう
もしもやがて個が消えて死んでしまったところで
素晴らしい慈悲も生まれてきて
そこで究極な幸福も生まれてくるんです
人間の中で生きている間は
解脱とはちょっと違いますけど
それはこの人間に味わえる最高の幸福には
2つあるんです
一つは「心の幸福」というんです
それは慈悲から生まれるんです
心の安らぎ
幸福は「慈悲の瞑想を完成」したら出てくるんです
それ（その幸福）は生きている間（だけ）
また死んじゃったら　それを忘れるかもしれませんね
それで（２つ目に）「智慧の幸福」があるんです
また　ヴィパッサナー的な瞑想などをして智慧を得たならば
心が完全に綺麗になったならば　悟れるんです
それで「最終的な幸福」も得られるんです
ですから
仏教では生きている間は
我々は慈悲の瞑想によって幸福を味わって　究極的な（幸福を）
それでさらに修行して
煩悩をなくし
悟りも得るという
2つの目的を考えているんです
そういうことで
今人間関係のことだけ喋ってますから
人間の間で　私たちは慈悲の心を持ち続けると
個ということ
「自分のこと」に　もう気が回らないんです
「自分のこと
自分のこと」ということを　心配しなくなって
「みんな幸福であれば　それでいいんじゃないか？」と
これ（慈悲を実践すること）はすごい立派な人間になるんです
想像でできないようなことまで　できるようになってくるんです
そうすると
何の問題もなく
あまりにも美しい人間関係が生まれてくる
友達だ　友達だとか
たくさん友達がいたとしても　迷惑でしょ
電話かけなくちゃいけない
手紙書けなくちゃいけない
いろいろお土産送らなくちゃいけない
ああだこうだとか考えてみてください
みんな「いっぱい人間関係できればいい」と思っちゃいますけど
100人
200人ぐらい友達がいたならば
自分の誕生日にも誰を呼ぼうか？　とか
大変危なくてしょうがないでしょうに
10人しか呼べないんだと
それで 「10人を呼んだ」と
呼んだんだ
でも自分には
100人ぐらい友達がいるんだと
その（呼んでない）人々に知られたらどうするんですか？
ですから
そんなこの「（その他の）人間とも仲良くなれなれ」と
「何人とも付き合う」ということは
これはえらい迷惑なんです
やりきれないんです
それは（良い）人間関係じゃないんです
これは大変な迷惑なんです
できるだけ「自分にコントロールできるぐらいの人々」と具体的に付き合えばいいし
それと　違って我々は「人を助けてあげる」と
「見返りを求めていない」と
で　そうすると
なんか言葉でちょっと言いにくいんだけれど
なんかすごい素晴らしく
どんな人とでもなんとなく喋る
なんとなくお互いにやり取りする
だからといってお互いにストレスは感じない
もし住所でも交換したならば
もし何か後で思い出したら電話して
ああ　そうです
この間の人
「ああ　よかったよかった」とかね
そういう風になるような
美しい「レベルが高い」人間関係が生まれてくるんです
そこは強引にやらないと自然には続いてこない
「慈悲の行動」は
それ（慈悲の行動）はどうやってやりますか？と
これを強引にやるときでも
こういう風に実行してみたらどうですか？
例えば皆様方は会社で仕事をする
会社で仕事をするとよく腹が立つんですね
あれは何でしょうか？と
自分がした仕事を「褒めてほしい」んですね
ちゃんと褒めて評価してもらわないと機嫌が悪い
それでトラブルを起こしちゃうんです
それは当たり前で
みんな自分のためにやってるんだから
褒めてもらったら自己が喜ぶんです
向こう側もそれなりに忙しい「個」だから
褒めるぐらい知恵が回るかどうかも分からないし
めんどくさい時に
一つ一つ褒めて　褒めまくっていくと
本人も個人だから　もう褒めませんね
褒めてくれません
それでどんな会社でもお互いに仲が悪くなっちゃうんです
仲が　そうじゃなくて
私は会社に行く
それで　できるだけ立派に仕事をすると
私に任せた仕事は
私は徹底的にやると
それは上司に認められても認められなくても
上司がその日は休みを取っていたり　来ていたとしても
来なかったとしても
私がやった仕事を
隣の人が自分がやったように上司に告げても　告げなくても関係ないんだと
私はこの会社から給料をもらってるんだから
今日 1 日の給料分をいっぱいこの仕事をしてやりました
ああ　良かったと
今日 1 日は
今日 1 日は正直に生きてられるんだと
今日 1 日の食べるご飯は全く「ツケ」ではないんだと
「ちゃんと真面目に仕事をしたんだから」と
ですから
かすかにでも褒めてほしい
認めてほしいという気持ちは消す
それを消せない場合は　もうちょっと威張ってください
あなた方なんかに認めてくれなくてもいいんだと
私は私に正直に生きてるんだ　と
そういうふうに威張ったらやりやすいかもしれません
で　上司が「あなた　昨日　本当に素晴らしい仕事をしました」
「だから？」と「ありがとうございます」とか
そんなこともなく
「ただの仕事でしょう？」と言われた方が
上司に対しても気持ちがいいんです
なんかね
グルグル挨拶回るわ
体曲げるわ曲げるわ
ヘビみたいですけどね
そこまで負けて負けて礼をしちゃうと
向こう側もその分ストレスがかかっちゃうんですね
ですから
「自分が完璧に仕事をしました」と
それで「認めてほしいかどうか」という気持ちもなかったと
上司が認めて褒めても
「そんなことは
どうせ私の仕事だから」ということで
そういうふうにお互いにリラックスさせるように
相手にストレスかからないようにやること　と
で　会社でもそれは私が今言ってる「introvert」の「内向的」な子が「社交的」になること　なんです
日本では人を助けようと思ったって
なかなか「助けを欲しがってる人」はいませんから
それはちょっと難しいかもしれません
でも　自分が毎日行ってる会社でそれをできる
そこで奥様方は料理をする
旦那が遅れてくる
それで腹が立って腹が立って
せっかく作った美味しいものはもう冷めちゃって
もう（美味しく）食べられなくなっちゃったと
一体この人は何時に来るんですか？と
自分がこれを（旦那に）美味しく食べてくれて「褒めてほしい」という気持ちがあるんだから
この気持ちが生まれてくる
ですから
そういう気持ちじゃなくて
「とにかく立派に美味しく料理を作るんだ」と
で　「それで自分の仕事は終わった」と
そうすると向こう側も「やっぱりあれほど一生懸命作ってるんだから」と
「やっぱり美味しく食べなくちゃいけない」と思って食べてくれるんです
いちいち「今日は　今日の料理はどう？」とかね
いちいちしつこく聞く必要はないんです
その場合は「褒めてほしい」という「人間の弱み」がそこにあるんですね
「褒めてほしいのは普通」なんです
なぜならば「自己」がやるんだから
それで「敵」が出来上がっちゃうんですね
かえって
だから「それはやめましょう」と
内向的じゃなくて
社交的に
ちょっと　ほんのちょっとやってみようと
電車で座席を人に譲る　と
なんか椅子を譲ってあげたら
なにか（身体が）弱い人は「座りたがらない」んですね
「あげ方」がまずいんです
私があげちゃったら確実に座るんです
なぜかというと
例えば「ちょっと（身体が）弱いような人」が来て
僕が座っていたならば
なんか「サッ」と立って
なんか「嫌な人が来た」ような感じで
ちょっと他のところに行くんですね
ほんのちょっと　（私が他へ）行ったら向こう側から見れば
あ　「座席が空いてる」んじゃないか？
私も体も弱いから座ろうと
「人から譲ってもらった」っていうことが（向こうには）さっぱりわからない
さっぱりわからない（気づかれない）
大体そういう場面でも　この（慈悲の）行動はできるんです
「そういうふうに人助けはするもの」なんです
「特別に何かする」ということよりは
「毎日我々やっていること」の人との関係だから
料理を作ることも人間関係で
お風呂を入れることも人間関係で
お化粧することも人間関係で
すべて人間関係でしょうに
ですから
毎日の人間関係を　自己のためではなくて　（このようにする）
例えば女性の方々はお化粧をする
全部「自己を膨張したい」と思ってやっているんだから
結局　結果としては
私は平気で言いますけれど
あんまり「最高得点」は得られませんよ？
自分で「好き勝手に自分の好み」でお化粧したとしても
自分だけで見たければ
自分の部屋に鍵をかけて
やりたい放題やってもいいんだけど
これは迷惑じゃないですか？
（なぜならば）外へ出るんですね
で　外へ出るならば
「人が見て　どういうふうにその人が気持ちよくなるか」ということで
お化粧のシステムを変えれば
もっと違うかもしれません
その時に「人にどう見られるか？」
「どう見られるか？」と思ったら
「自分のこと」なんですね
そういうことではなくて
そこら辺はね？
いくらこんな
例えば「豪華な指輪を持ってる」のだと
いくら豪華なものがあっても
そんなものをはめても
そこに行くんだったら　いいわ
こんな「安いもの」をはめていくんだ　と
そういうふうな感じで
この「自分」が「自分のため」にお化粧するんじゃなくて
社会でみんな　それなりに気持ちよく
明るく　違和感なく（調和して）居られるためのものだ　と
そういうふうに
お化粧でも「そういうふうにできる」んですよ
「人の助け」になるように
「何でもできる」んです
なぜなら
我々は何でも「自分のために」やる
その「自分のためにやる」ことは
ちょっと変えて　「立場を変えて」みる
同じこと
それから我々がやっているすべてが人間の付き合い
人間関係なんですね
「人間関係でなくやるもの」は何でしょうかね？
たとえご飯食べる時でも
いろいろね
「みんなと一緒に食べる」んだから
それも人間関係なんですね
ですから
ご飯を食べると自分
自分が好き勝手に食べても全く　かえっていけないでしょうに
日本でよくやりますよ？
「指を舐めたり」とかね？
外国人から見れば
「結構失礼な態度」なんですけどね
一応日本には　日本なりのしきたりがありますけれど
「それを自分勝手に破る」わけじゃなくて
ちゃんと「いい雰囲気を作って食べる」とか
「食べること」さえ　人間関係なんです
ということで
我々にとっては　この「内向的な自分」を　少々「社交的な自分」に入れ替える
入れ替えると
特別に「友達」と　「友達の首の数が大きくなる」ということではなくて
「人間の関係」がすごく素晴らしく
トラブルがない
コンフリクト（衝突、対立）のない
「ぶつかり合うことなく」うまくいってしまうんです
うまく社会に溶け込んで　うまくいってしまうんです
で　もっとまた理解するために必要なんですけど
（何でしたっけ？）
これは「慈悲」という言葉で理解してもいいし
で　もう一つ理解する方法があるんです
この「私はわがまま」ですが
「私はわがままが大嫌い」でしょう？
大体世の中って　「私はわがまま」です
でも　「この人々は本当にわがままで嫌な人だな」と
大体世の中そんなものなんです
だから「いい人間関係」は生まれてこない
自分がわがまま
でも人があまりにもわがままになっちゃうと
あんたあまりにもわがままだから
あなたとは付き合うことはできませんと
これからあなたとは商売はできませんと
あなたの会社はあまりにも自分の利益ばっかり考えているのだから
あなたの会社とはもうやり取りしませんとか
会社にしたとしても「わがままだったら嫌」だと
個人個人の場合でも
「わがままな人とは付き合いたくない」という立場があるんですね
それは合理的に言えば　こういう論理なんですね
「私はわがまま」ですが
「人のわがままは絶対許せません」とか
「わがままな人は大嫌い」ですよ　と
あるいは他の言葉で言えば
「私はわがまま」ですが
「世の中の人間は絶対にわがままになってはいけません」と
「私のために」と
そういう考え方で生きているんです
この人間がなんとなく　このように（わがままに）人間が生きてますけど
「自分が生きている哲学」はわからないんですね
お釈迦様は「この哲学」を教えてくれる
「あなたの哲学はそういう哲学だよ」と　教えてくれたら腹が立ちますけれども
「なんと失礼なことですか？」と
でも真実なんですね
それでこの人（お釈迦様から教えられた人）は立派になってしまうんです
そういうことで
「私はわがまま」ですし
で　「私は客観的に人のわがままを見る」と
ものすごい気持ち悪いし
それだったら　「自分自身が超気持ち悪い人間」だと
（なぜならば）「他の人から（私を）見ればわがまま」でしょう？
（だから）「超気持ち悪い」んです
だから「自分がもう散々嫌われているんだ」と
たとえ「微かなアポイント」にしたとしても
自分が何か用事があって
向こうに電話して用事がありますけれども
明日 2時はどうですか？　と
そしたら向こうは　あの
2時と言われても
2時半だったら時間ありますけれど　と
あの　実はですね
私は 2時半に（なんとかかんとか）　買い物に行かなくちゃいけないんだけど
2時だったら本当に便利（都合がいいの）ですけれど
別に（あなた何も）　このごろ何もやってないでしょう？
ですから 「2時に会いましょうよ？」と言ったら
向こう側はこちらの都合の
2時に会うんですね
友達同士だったら（そんなことは）なんのことでもないかもしれませんけれどね
それくらいのことでも「こちらのわがまま」なんですね
で　向こう側がなんとなく「微かに嫌だな」と
「ああ　仕方がない
２時に会ってあげなくちゃいけない」となってしまうんですね
そういうふうなことで
我々はいつでも　この「人のわがまま」で結構痛い目に遭ってるんです
これ　毎日遭ってるんです
自分も「自分がわがまま」で
「みんなを嫌な気持ちにして」いるんです
ですから
「これは怖い」と感じる
「わがままな自分が醜い」んだと
「わがままな自分が嫌われる」んだと
「わがままな自分が損をする」んだと
「自分がわがままだから　人間関係がうまくいかない」んだと
ですから
自分のことを置いておいて
かすかにでも人のことを考えましょう　と
というふうなことでも
一つの方法
手段なんですね
この手段の場合は
この「わがままは嫌われる」と覚えておくんですね
「わがままは嫌われる」
「不幸の元である」と覚えておけば
なんとなく自分の心から「わがまま」は消えていってしまう
それで人のわがままを見ると
「あんたわがままではないか」と子供に言う必要もないんです
その時　瞬間に
私はわがままで
自分の「意の通り」に子供は行動して欲しかった
子供はそうはやってないんだから
私は子供をわがままだと思ってるんだ　と理解すればうまくいくんです
会社で散々仕事をさせちゃうと
自分は休みを取りたいんだと
そうすると会社の社長やら部長やら上司やら
すごいわがままで
自分のことしか考えなくて
自分はいつでも仕事に呼ばれるんだと
そんなことを考えるんじゃなくて
「自分が休みたい」
わがままだから
それで会社の人は「会社のために私を呼びたい」と
だから私は腹が立ったんだ
「私がわがままだから腹が立ったんだ」と理解しておけば
そこで問題は解決する
こういうふうな方法で
一応　人間関係はなんとか出来上がるだろうと思います
この慈悲　「慈悲喜捨」と４つの立場がありますけどね
慈っていうのは「友情」で
悲は悲しむ
「悩んでいる人々を助けてあげること」で
喜っていうのは「人の喜びを自分でも喜ぶこと」で
捨っていうのは「何ものがあっても驚かないような気持ち」なんですね
何でもありきと認める心で
ですから
慈悲喜捨なんです
で　それを適当に実行すると
毎日幸福になっていくんですね
それからこの仕事をしたり
いろんなことをすると
私たちはこの「仕事自体を楽しむ事」と「褒めてもらいたい」という
この「後の話（褒めてもらいたい）」じゃなくて
言葉で言えば　こういうことには「結果を楽しむんじゃなくて
過程を楽しむ」と
仕事をする
それで「結果を楽しむ」という人は
いい仕事をして
もう会社がいっぱい儲かって　儲けさせてあげて
「会社から表彰状をもらおうと思う」とする
で　そこから苦しみが生まれてくるんですね
もし他の人がもっといい仕事をしたならば
その人が表彰状もらっちゃいますから
で　悔しくてしょうがないんですね
自分が苦労して仕事をしたのに
で　不幸になってしまうんですね
「相手がライバル」になってしまうんです
そういうわけで
「誰が表彰状をもらっても
それは関係ないんだ」と
10人で仕事をするならば
一番点数高いのが誰であろうと
それは関係ないんだ　と
私はその「仕事を楽しんで」充実してやりますと
言って「過程を楽しむ」
「結果」ではなくて
結果はあまり気にしない
ちょっと失礼な言葉なんですけど
「結果について　そんなにこだわらない」んだ　と
その「過程を楽しむ」ということも
また一つ大変いい「ありがたいこと」なんです
人間　結果を見て褒めてもらいたいんだからね
ですから
慈悲のことを実践するとは
ただ単に人に優しくしてあげることだけ楽しむ
悩んでいる人をそれなりに助けてあげる
相談に乗ってあげる
それだけ楽しむ
例えば人が悩み事を言ってくれた　と
こちらはなんとか相談にのってあげて
それから「この頃　どうですか？」と
ああだこうだ
ああだ　と「いろいろ聞く」でしょ？
「これからどうです？」
「どうなったんですか？」
とかね 「よかったでしょうね？」とかね
僕はあんまり　あの言葉は好きじゃないですね
「ああ　この間本当に良かった
良かった」とかね
「これ良かったですね
良かったですね」
これは「強引にその人を責める」ことなんです
その人が「本当に感謝したがってるかそうでないか　分からない」のだから
「失礼」なんです
たとえば　私が人に何か教えてあげる
それで第三者がそれを待っている
（その第三者が）「あ　ちゃんと質問に答えてもらってよかったですね」
「よかったですね」とか言うと
その人の態度を強引に責めることなんです
本当に良かったかそうでないか
その本人の問題だから
そこで「ああ　そうですね」と嫌々言わなくちゃいけない場合はどうするんですかね？
「よかったよかった」
なんで「よかったですね
よかったですね」とか
「自分で（自分自身に）暗示をかける」ようにしてあげるんですかね？
よくやるでしょ？
普通だったら
「よかった」んだったら「本人のこと」だから
「本人が一番よく知ってる」はずでしょうに
関係ない人々が
一生懸命「暗示」をかけるんですよ
「よかったですね」
「よかったですね」と
あれ　「すごい失礼」だなと思いますよ
ですから
とにかく我々は
この人から「よかった」とか「なんとか」ということを言われる
それもストレスになっちゃうし
人を助けてあげる
ただ質問されたら答える
ちょっと悩み事があって
それを打ち明けたら
それはちゃんと聞いてあげると
それで　「よかったか　そうでないか」っていうのは
それは「その人の問題」で
自分が過程だけ楽しむ
いい仕事をしようではないかと
人の悩み事をやっぱり真剣に聞いてあげましょうと
その過程だけ楽しんで
それで終わると
慈悲喜捨の実行はできるんです
（えーっと）
まだ喋るのならば
次のポイントに行きます